[Music]
it's totally predator
yeah this one here is actually sonar do
you think
souls come back to visit
oh my goodness so
we are in the basement at the cbs
broadcast center
it was a dairy farm a sort of like fake
vegetarian
i like to think of dairy cows as living
a wonderful life
and living to a ripe old age
and they enjoyed being milked but every
mother can relate to that
we all have to have do you think that
souls come back to visit places
i do think that i mean nobody knows for
sure the mechanics behind it
if there's conscious thought if there's
a decision or if they're
you know here for a reason that we don't
know
but i do think it can happen yeah what
we usually try to do
is build rapport with whatever could be
here
you know give it some sort of verbal
trigger
i say you had passed and you didn't want
somebody in here or you didn't even care
about somebody being in here
you might be more likely to interact
with them if they
you know maybe say your mother's name or
mention things that you're familiar with
or things that you
are interested in so we'll try that type
of scenario when we're looking for any
sort of
you know ghostly type of okay see it i
see a dot
like that's you here but there's
something there with mass
there's something there with ass
okay it's still there steve what is this
so the cows were in here the cows were
in here yep
they found a hoof down here we're really
focused on
you know energy and how it moves and
interacts with the environment
you know so what was this like when this
was a
a dairy farm you know this is not the
first place i would call a meeting
unless you're making like blair witch 3.
oh oh
oh oh everything like
goes wrong in my life i hit that box of
macaroni and cheese real hard
you do need dairy to make
macaroni and cheese you absolutely do
with no harm to a cow
just some milking oh my god
i love that ladder i need that
oh gosh
i mean i really need this in my
apartment
i'm just saying we all need a ladder
okay steve
thank you for coming on the show now
we didn't find any ghosts but we did
find a fabulous ladder
um that said what can people do at home
because you have all this fancy
equipment
and it really is impressive what do
people do that don't have the fancy
equipment when they want to find ghosts
there are a lot of things that people
can do
at home one thing that we do is a
rapport building technique called
call and response where you're using any
kind of
information that you can use as a verbal
trigger to get a response and if
people you know can't afford all the
gadgetry like we have
a compass can be used if a compass can't
find magnetic north then there's
something there
messing with the energy in the
environment
i love a compass i also think it makes
one of the greatest gifts
and you can say you're my north star oh
that's really sweet
well i love that you love energy so much
because i'm a big believer in
energy and i have to say hanging out
with you in such a
kind of intimidating environment like i
had no idea that that was lurking below
um i knew that it was a dairy farm but i
pictured it very differently
and being down there with you i felt
very safe so you have good energy
thank you very much i see you have the
latter right there that you
you know listen i could have gone on
etsy which by the way i just hosted the
etsy awards i'm a big fan but i'm like
an antique ladder
like you know i'm just gonna take it
anyway thank you steve
you can catch steve in the two-hour
special ghost nation reunion in hell
airing on halloween night on the travel
channel
steve thank you so much you are so
lovely my pleasure
[Music]